bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons tout de suite l'édition de ce
mercredi 22 janvier le 2e la deuxème
édition du trempelin chanson les envoles
du scarabé démarre dans quelques
semaines comment y participer toutes les
précisions avec notre invité dans
quelques instants la batterie aguille en
cours propose de découvrir le 25 janvier
trois groupes en devenir portrait de
bazar et bémol au cours de leur
résidence qui précède le concert
vendredi 31 janvier l'espace de Coville
la Voisin accueille hip hop tour session
au programme musique danse et Open Mik
Nicolas Gervet a rencontré Miss Kylie la
MC de la soirée alors le scarabé à La
Verrière développe depuis quelques
années une identité chanson dans sa
programmation que ce soit des artistes
reconnus ou en devenir c'est notamment
les rencontres et les découvertes faites
au cours de festival qui ont donné
l'idée à son directeur et programmateur
de créer un trempelin de chansons
françaises bonsoir Samuel Denis bonsoir
vous êtes ce fameux directeur et
programmateur donc du scaravé alors ce
petit montauan yvelinois voilà oui en
fait montauan c'est un pourtiv j'ai
découvert il y a 4 ans 5 ans maintenant
et euh et c'est ce qui vous a donné C
voilà j'ai découvert ce festival et en
fait il ils sont structurés au niveau
national pour ramener sur ce festival 12
12 découvertes chansons duus des
différentes régions et donc il y a un
jury professionnel un jury public
constituer toutes les personnes qui
peuvent assister au 4 après-midi c'est
l'après-midi en fait et donc il voilà
moi je me suis dit j'ai beaucoup de
demandes de groupe pas amateur mais
disons pas
pas très médiatisé des environs qui
voudrait passer au scarabé je me suisens
pourquoi pas faire un petit motoban à
l'échelle locale alors quel est le
principe là exactement du coup combien
de groupes ou artistes alors on a tout
récent la première édition céit l'année
dernière donc c'était limité aux
ivelines il fallait que la moitié au
moins du groupe soit résident dans le
département des ivelines donc il y a eu
31 candidatures euh je sais pas combi de
candatur comment vous faites vous
recevez 31 candidatures comment je les
écoute alors ça qu'est-ce qu'ils
envoient comment comment il postulent le
le ce qu'on demande le minimum c'est
d'envoyer un CD trois titres parce que
sur un titre ça VI c'est difficile de
juger des fois il y a un groupe qui ils
ont un CD 12 titres il m'envoie le CD 12
titres j'écoute les 12 d'accord mais bon
c'est vrai que je pourrais m'arrêter à
TR mais je me dis voilà si qu'on on plus
j'en écoute plus donc c'est minimum
trois titres et en fonction de ça
effectivement là on peut dire que c'est
un c'est pas très démocratique puisque
c'est moi qui dé voà j'ai écouté les 31
et sur les 31 je suis très rapidement
descendu à 15 pour arriver de 15 à 9 ça
était plus dur jeouté 5 six fois en me
disant bon celui-là non celui-là plutôt
oui il un moment il faut arriver à 9
donc il faut trancher et d'ailleurs le
10e le 11e et le 12e je leur envoyé un
mail en leur disant voilà vous
malheureusement vous êtes 10e donc vous
serez pas sur le plateau du scarabé mais
alors cette année ils peuvent retenter
leur chance ceux-l c'est il y en a déjà
qui ont retenter leur chance là c'est ça
donc là l'appel à candidature est est
lancé donc c'est jusqu'au 28 février
jusqu'au 28 février donc pour envoyer
son CD donc de trois titres euh donc on
disait s'est ouvert au département
limitrophe donc on va les citer donc
aller au scè valdoise l' encore dit mais
on justement c'est la nouveauté de cette
année c'est pour pas retomber je me suis
dit si on repart sur la même chose on va
retrouver à peu près les mêmes groupes
parce qu'on en un an il y a pas il y a
pas 40 groupes différents qui se sont
créés autour de la chanson dans les
yvelin j'ai dis on va ouvrir au
département limitrophe ce qui a pour
effet pour l'instant de laisser le 75 à
part parce que sinon on un trempin
national quoi là donc là on appelle ça
le tremplin du grand ouest parisien donc
78 28 27 donc côté ouest et 8 92 91 côté
Paris ça fait quand même si départements
donc 31 candidatures pour lesin l'année
dernière là sur 6 départements à mon
avis on est on devrait monter à 60 70
candidatures pour l'instant c'est 16
j'en ai 16 au jour d'aujourd'hui où on
parle j'en ai 16 16 alors qu'est-ce qui
est important parce que c'est un
trempelin de chanson française votre
sensibilité à vous elle est portée sur
quoi alors le seul le seul critère
obligatoire c'est les textes en français
h ensuite c'est délicat puisqu'il des
surtout au niveau du on va dire du rock
il y a a il peut y avoir un groupe de
j'ai jamais eu unn dernière un groupe de
métal de Rambouillet d'ailles je peux
les nommer ouou il s'appelle Malatesta
moi je trouve ça très bien sauf
qu'effectivement la musique et a plus de
50 % de de de de l' l'entité globale
artistique les textes sont un peu en
arrière c'estd des fois on ah qu'est-ce
qu'il a dit on a pas bien compris parce
que parce que ça envoie de la guitare
par que ça envoie la batterie donc ça ça
dénature en rien la qualité du groupe
mais pour ce tremplin chanson euh moi je
fais une différence entre du Rock EN
français et et de la chanson rock c'estd
qu'il peut y avoir effectivement
d'ailleurs le le on pourra le dire tout
à l'heure le gagnant de la première
édition donc là c'est pas moi qui l'ai
fait gagner moi j'en ai sélectionné neuf
il se trouve qu'il y a eu un gagnant
avec par l'intermédiaire du jury pro du
jury public qu'on expliquera ensuite
c'était le groupe le plus rock de la
sélection alors moi ce que je vous
propose c'est que justement on écoute et
on regarde un extrait donc des trois
lauréas de l'édition précédente ça nous
donnera une idée justement du niveau qui
est attendu du style
ou je t'ai emmené à Lyon pas la rosette
et
puisimais pas les galettes je t'ai
emmené à parisaimais pas le PSG moi ma
spécialité c'est des histoires d'amour
raté Motot son tu le cuueilles pleur à
pleur ton amour tu les feuilles
elle
t'esffleur et danse avec ton
cœur 1 2 3 1 2 3 1 2 3 entends-tu la
musique 2 3 mélodie frénétique 3 1 2 3
comme l'instant est magine 2 3 1 2 3 1 2
3 is jour est arrivé comme un coup de
tonner une lettre pour me remercier de
mes années d'enfer le cœur à genou la
gueule dans un V ma fierté prend un
coup se retrouve sous
terre nous on voulait pas
grand-chose un bouleau du vin des gens
et des sentiments nous donc là on a pu
s'apercevoir de donc du niveau de
l'année dernière donc on attend je
suppose la même chose peut-être même
encore mieux ce frappant c'est la
différence entre rien à voir les a les
autres tous les styles sont les
bienvenus ils ont juste en commun le
fait qu'ils chantent en français qui ont
des textes audibles et qui disent des
choses quoi de façon humoristique pour
Al baron qui av fin 3è de façon plus
poétique pour pour Fab m de rambouiller
et puis de tout façon plus rock and roll
sur jagagas de conf de
conflanintonorine alors comment comment
comment ça se passe le soir ces fameux
soir alors donc c'est on va donner les
dates parce que c'est le 6 7 et 8 juin 8
Ju c'est sur le weekend de la Pentecôte
trois soirée consécutive ouais vendredi
samedi et dimanche puisque le lundi est
férier donc les neuf groupes sont
sélectionnés dès que l'app à candidature
est fini là au 28 février vous allez
comment vous répartissez qui sur quelle
date alors là il y a pas
de on veut on veut pas que des gens nous
disent moi je me rappelle l'année
dernière il y avait un gars qui m'avait
dit iltait en guitare solo il m'avait
dit j'aimerais bien commencer une soirée
n'importe laquelle des TR mais je
voudrais bien être le premier parce que
je suis tout seul avec ma guitare je dit
non bon le tirage au sort a fait qu'il a
eu de la chance il est arrivé il est
arrivé c'està qu' a les neuf groupes et
les neuf groupes on va en fait un tirage
au sort et donc ils sont répartis sur
trois soirées et l'ordre de passage des
groupes c'est le premier qu'on tire il
passera le premier le premier soir et
cetera et cetera comme ça donc il joue
leur 7 de 40 minutes 40 minutes ouais il
faut avoir 40 minutes pour postuler
c'est ça envoyer un CD TR titres c'est
bien mais il faut aussi avoir 40 minutes
de de Live derrière quo bien sûr et
alors ensuite comment intervient le le
jury comment ça se passe qui d'abord on
va direz alors j'ai j'ai j'ai tout
simplement copié sur
motoban façon très simple à motoban le
jury professionnel c'est 21 21
professionnels des différents festivals
francophones donc il y a des Suisses des
Belges des Québécois et évidemment des
Français moi jeen je suis pas aller
chercher si loin ça sera un jury nous le
voilà le jurier est essentiellement
verrierrois ouis donc on dit qui non si
bah il y a neuf personnes il y a neuf
personnes voilà des des représentant du
scarabé donc vous voilà donc on est
trois du scarabé euh puisque nous on
voit de la chanson scarabé euh toute
l'année donc c'est vrai qu'on il a même
à priori de ne porter un jugement il y a
le directeur de l'école de musique et de
danse de la berrière il y a Ivan daautin
qui est donc un chanteur artiste qu'un
artiste ou qui a eu ces heur de glir
dans l' années 80 il est moins connu
maintenant mais il a vraiment il a fait
un tas d'album il fait encore de la
scène d'ailleurs et donc il participe au
jury des envols il y a une ma
chef une il y a oui il y a il y a l'élu
à la culture il y a aussi ma la
directrice des services à la population
qui est donc ma responsable en mairie
donc en fait vous avez tous quand même
des sensibilités différentes qui
différents ouais Ivan il a il a au moins
60 ans et ça va et Camilla qui travaille
à l'action culturelle au scarabé en a 30
quoi donc VO c'est et alors le jury
public puisqueon a dit il y a un jury
professionnel un jury constitué du
public alors voilà là il y a une
condition quand même qui est important n
exp c'est là le modèle motoban c'est de
dire les personnes qui ont assisté aux
trois soirées donc ça le premier jour
ils viennent on leur donne un bulletin
de vote deème jour on leur met un tampon
sur ce bulletin de vote qui prouve bien
qu' qui sont venus 3ème jour rebelote et
à la fin de la 3ème soirée on ramasse
les bulletins de vote donc forcément
ceux qui peuvent voter c'est ceux qui
ont assisté aux trois soirées voilà ça
c'est la condition faut être présent au
trois soiré il faut être présent au TR
soirées donc ce qui cette année coûtera
10 € puisquon est sur un un tarif par
soir à 5 € donc très accessible et même
un passe pour les 3 jours à 10 € qu'on
avait pas l'année dernières bien un
passe 10 € pour les 3 soirs et les gens
votent et ensuite on fait un un petit
calcul mathématique c'estàd que le vote
du jury professionnel a un coefficient 2
h du juré public a un coefficient 1 on
mélange tout ça et ça nous donne un trio
gagnant OK et il y a un petit cadeau
quand même qu'on avait déjà fait la
dernière et qu'on va refaire cette année
c'est que dans le jury public l'année
dernière ils étaient 12 à avoir fait les
trois soirées on a tiré au sort c'est
d'ailleurs un des gars de jagas qui a
tiré au sort les gagnants qui a tiré une
personne au sort et qui va avoir un
passe intégral motoban pour mai 2014 4
jours de motoban gratuit valeur
marchande 150 € quand même donc c'est
plutôt sympa donc on va le refaire cette
année c'est on a un petit peu pris par
le temps Sam on va le refaire cette
année faire pour le motoban 2015 ok
alors on rappelle que les candidatures
donc sont adressées au scarabé jusqu'au
28 février et rapidement on dit
également que vendredi vous vous vous
présentez une création aour de toupac
l'icône du rap des années 90 et le 7
février pas des moins que Elmer footbeit
revient sur So rigolade le 7 février
donc Philippe de Monte la jolie en
première partie de Elmer foot beat le
retour bon et ben écoutez ça sera ça
s'annonce une belle soirée ça on bien
merci Samuel d'être venu dans le C alors
on reste dans le registre de la chanson
française et je vous propose de
découvrir le groupe bazar et bémol un
trio originaire des Yvelines qui sera
sur scène le 25 janvier donc à la
batterie à Guill encour nous les avons
rencontré au cours de leur résidence
image de Jonathan villman et d'Etienne
Dang venez faire vre F
C ch et Raphaël trois musiciens
talentueux trois amis aussi qui depuis 6
ans forment le groupe bazar et bémol
leurs études achevé fin 2010 il décide
de faire de la musique une activité
professionnelle de la chanson française
swing teintée de multiples influences du
coup tout l'intérêt pour nous c'est de
sortir des clichés de la chanson
française pour essayer de faire quelque
chose un peu voilà avec d'autres styles
une vraie complémentarité entre chacun
tant dans la composition que dans
l'écriture des textes une plume soignée
que avec énergie humour ce trio
festif on écrit tous les trois et mais
onécrit pas ensemble puis après on fait
les arrangements ensemble et le texte
quand en tout cas la phase d'écriture le
texte est très important on écrit juste
texte et la mélodie est là pour mettre
avant le texte et voilà c'est pour ça
qu'il y a un travail d'écriture très
important sur la la forme des mots qu'on
va utiliser on veut que ce soit le plus
poétique possible leurs premières scènes
ont lieu dans les rames du métro
parisien puis de place publi en cabaret
la mise en scène du spectacle prend une
nouvelle dimension une transition
s'opère un changement d'échelle qui
nécessite de porter un nouveau regard
sur le show après un travail de
résidence avec les studios de la
batterie à Guill en cour ils se
produiront sur scène le 25 janvier la
résidence c'est c'est assez intense
parce que c'est sur 3 jours 3 4 jours on
est vraiment tous les jours à avoir
beaucoup beaucoup d'idées et comme Alex
Christophe et Fab nous le disent
régulièrement c'est que voilà nous on
vous donne des idées vous les prenez
vous les mettez en place et puis après
vous vous réfléchissez et vous vous
prenez celle-là vous prenez celle-l vous
éjectez cl et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant en fait c'est de recevoir
cet afflux d'information en plus d'un
autre regard que notre metur en scène
habituelle et trier et voir qu'est-ce
qui peut être le mieux dans notre
spectacle quoi la sortie de leur premier
album est prévu pour début 2015 pr de
toute science et de toutes manièr
retrouvons sans plus attendre Nicolas
Gervet pour sa
chronique l'espace de Coville à voisin
le breteneux donc accueille le 31
janvier le hip hop tour session au
programme musique danse et Open Mike et
Nicolas Gervet a rencontré Miss Kylie la
MC de la soirée on l'écoute amis du
Hipop bonjour le 31 janvier metasos
organise l'événement gratuit hip hop
tour session avec un groupe de la danse
et un open Mik pour nous en parler notre
rappeuse préférée voici Miss kaellie
dans le
kiosk Tristan président de metasos est
venu me voir aux scènes slam que j'anime
au Marina au café Le Marina tous les
mois et en fin de saison l'année
dernière et il m'a dit qu'il souhaitait
programmer une date hip hop à la salle
de de la tour l'idée c'est vraiment de
proposer plusieurs disciplines du hiphop
elles seront pas toutes là mais il y
aura du diging du
msing de la
danse danse debout Coré comme du Crump
et du freestyle et du
beatbox dans les
loganchement jusqu'à onêtre en âge
mission un délire de partage même si on
avance en marche pas nous STO on est en
forme un groupe d'tizou qui sera en
chocis en première partie de
soirée pendant un bon 45 minutes je
pense voilà detizou qui est un groupe
local c'est un groupe issu de de morpa
dans le coin
et et dans le cadre du EV life de leur
accompagnement avec masos il faut un
gros concert ce soir-là pour démarrer la
soirée bien comme il faut monadre mon
crois que Mo alors que je prends du
recul dans la surenchère pr àin1 DRAM il
y a une re perd 25g perd 21 gr Mik avec
mon CRE j'excite ma merère t les jours
je c mon trou car j'anticipe ma chaque
matin open Mik de de bonnes heures de
bonnes heur avec DJ platine et puis
beatboxer qui accompagne voilà et les MC
qui viennent et qui s'inscrivent bah sur
le moment avant chaque session ça sera
coupé en deux parties
et et du coup moi je suis chargé d'être
de cérémonies de de tout ce temps-là de
la soirée et et puis il y aura des des
attentats de danse qui arriveront quand
personne s'y
attend après le chocquess de dortizu il
y a une pause les gens viennent me voir
moi je les inscris et puis après je
distribue la parole je fais monter les
gens sur scène au fur et à mesure c'est
micro ouvert donc tu as quelque chose à
dire monte par contre
là message à tous les MC ramenez pas vos
instrus c'est pas vous qui choisirez il
y aura une musique un beatbox il aura
quelque chose et il faudra faire le TF
quoi TR moments dans cette soirée vont
être coupé par des breakers qui vont
arriver et qui vont envoyer du très gros
freestyle et pas forcément sur scène
voilà c'est-à-dire que il va y avoir des
des bains de
foule la danse va intervenir à des
endroits un peu improbables dans la
soirée et elle est là pour
surprendre les danseurs c'est des jeunes
qui s'entraînent au niveau de la BU la
bibliothèque universitaire à sa-quentin
et c'est des jeunes qui sont très
déterminé très corias dans le bon sens
c'est la relève donc j'avais vraiment
envie de les mettre en avant sur cet
événement parce que c'est ils sont
vraiment des forces vives du coin il
s'agit de du groupe CBC ils sont huit
beaucoup de Danes debout des battles
aussi dans au sol voilà ils se
produisent tous les weekends ils sont
vraiment vraiment activistes de cette
culture épop et puis zououf en c'est un
duo c'est un duo de de
freestyler de freestyler très très
fort y a pasy qu'on tapon on
alors et alors qui partipe ci moio je au
trop de ch à sur uneand deâoudrait et
lae anthè alorscali l'ct miscali c'est
un gros concert bientôt le 8
mars qui qui va couvrir la sortie de
l'album bienvenu en zone
franche un un concert qui aura lieu au
Café de la plage à morpa après plein de
petites scènes parisiennes et puis bah
toujours les scènes slam au Marina tous
les tous les premers mardis de chaque
mois c'est vraiment ouvert à tous et le
slam n'est pas n'est pas fermé on se dit
souvent en plus comme c'est moi qui
l'anime et qui suis rappeuse ça va être
très très rap très non en fait on va y
retrouver du compte du théâtre de la
danse plein de choses
ours m dans
Monin
je merci à vous le kiosque et gros big
up à masu voilà parce que
c'est bah la deuxème fois après la
Merise que une salle du coin vient nous
voir il nous disent on a envie de
programmer du hip hop voilà ils viennent
vers moi et puis on fait les choses bien
voilà puis à mon label der production
merci
Nico et voilà pour le hip hop tour
session présenté par Miss cellie et
maintenant on retrouve celle qui rappe
ses légumes tous les midis j'ai nommé
aurelliia nous sommes mercredi c'est
donc l'heure des sorties cyé au micro
d'éodim moine j'ai bien aimé c'est drôle
c'est caustique c'est plaisant c'est une
bonne distraction puis les acteurs sont
bien j'aime bien enfin moi j'aime les
aime tous alors ce soit Zabou bretman
Olivier Marchall ou audre fleurau ils
sont excellents c'est un bon
divertissement ça se regarde par contre
la Provence très très beau c'est très
bien filmé il y a des paysages
magnifiques bon ben je vous dis toujours
la même chose le triangle amoureux de
femmes qui se battent pour un homme et
puis bah voilà aller voir la fin aller
voir pour connaître la fin voilà c'est
tout j'ai vraiment très apprécié surtout
qu'il était euh très important parce que
c'était sur l'évolution de l'aviation je
pense que c'était en 1940 ou un peu
avant voilà super super super belle
réalisation tout à tout point de vue
toujours dans la lignée de tous les
miazaki euh cette fois-ci il y a
vraiment plus c'est plus réaliste c'est
plus euh peut-être on peut le trouver un
peu plus froid mais il va moins chercher
dans le rêve et il va plus chercher dans
en juste la vie quotidienne d'un d'un
garçon qui sait pas vraiment en fait ce
qu'il veut et c'est une fresque contre
l'esclavage assez classique voilà bon à
comparer avec le film de
Tarantino je dirais que Tarantino va va
beaucoup plus loin mais bon c'est c'est
un bon
film alors comme vous le savez la
chronique cinéphile c'est aussi
l'occasion d'entendre un professionnel
du cinéma nous donner son coup de cœur
et cette semaine c'est auutour de Gael
Pino responsable du grenier à sel
attrape on l'écoute bonjour cette
semaine je vais vous parler de mon coup
de cœur qui est old boy old boy c'est un
remake américain d'un film coréen un
remake du film qui s'appelait old boy
réalisé par parwook en 2004 et qui avait
eu le prix du jury à
can donc cette version là est réalisé
par spyey on y retrouve georh bling
c'est un film qui est très violent comme
l'original qui était très violent aussi
donc il est interdit au moins de 16 ans
et l'histoire c'est l'histoire d'un d'un
père de famille dans les fin des ann 80
qui est enlevé et séquestré pendant une
15 15 20 ans et il ne sait pas pourquoi
et un jour comme ça il est libéré
maintenant je vous laisse découvrir la
la suite on propose en version française
et en version originale au grenier àell
cette
semaine je vous propose à présent
quelques idées de sortie ces prochains
jours alors tout d'abord sous le
chapiteau de la base de loisirs à
Saint-Quentin en Yveline vous pouvez
assister à un spectacle cirque poétique
le bal des intouchables où les artistes
déjoueront ce qui semble impossible donc
ce sera vendredi samedi et dimanche en
fonction des horaires que vous aurez
choisi accessible des 8 ans vous pouvez
également à soirée assister pardon à une
soirée lyrique donc du belcanto
classique et romantique Mozart Puccini
Verdi interprété par des artiste de
l'Opéra de Paris et ce accompagné d'un
repas gastronomique ce sera donc à l'
staminé à anamo samedi à partir de 20h
et enfin vous pouvez également découvrir
les plus beaux classiques en espagnol
interprétés par Chico et les Gypsies à
l'occasion d'une représentation
exceptionnelle samedi également à 20h30
à la Ferme du Manet voilà notre édition
est à présent terminée je vous retrouve
la semaine prochaine en direct à 18h30 à
mercredi